well on balance I think trade has been
beneficial to the United States yes I
was majority leader when we passed naft
I supported it I supported the creation
of the world trade organization one of
the areas i tend to disagree with the
Democratic presidential candidates but
it's understandable their position is is
that we ought to well they don't quite
say we ought to repeal them but they say
we have to renegotiate them and then if
you can renegotiate them fine but you
can't deal with the other signatories of
these trees I think I think the debate
has been incomplete with respect to
trade it is true that it does produce
adverse effects of that there can be no
doubt it's like most public policy
issues but it also produces very
beneficial effects which we ought to
include in the debate and then a
discussion I do believe strongly that we
can do a much better job in negotiating
trade agreements to deal with the very
troubling issues of health healthcare
Environmental Protection very low wages
and other societies that is work of
protection issues to neutralize some of
the difficulties that we have we have
not done a good job at that but the
answer is not to build walls of
protection the answer is to keep what's
working and trade generally is
beneficial and try to deal with the
adverse effects the reality is of course
that there is dislocation there's much
dislocation but it's very hard to
identify a specific and direct
cause-and-effect relationship with
respect to all dislocation because much
of it comes from a dynamic free market
economy and you want innovation
you know they used to be a lot of people
in this country employed in the
manufacture of stagecoaches there run
any anymore they all when the motor
vehicle was invented the stagecoach
production ended and people have made
motor vehicles and that meant
dislocation for those who've been
engaged in stagecoach production and
other related industries but the
country's clearly better off that didn't
have any do with any trade agreement
that was the result of innovation and a
dynamic free market economy which we
have which we want in which we should
encourage I emphasize I'm not for just
trading for the sake of trading you have
to have an objective and we can do a
much better job at mitigating the
admittedly harsh effects on individuals
when I was a boy my mother as I
mentioned earlier was a textile mill
worker and she worked at a number of
mills I think at one time there were
about 20 textile mills of one kind or
another within an hour's drive of our
home I don't think there's a single one
now just gone first to the south and
then Asia and now there are real effects
to that main on another example was once
the largest manufacturer of all of the
states in production of footwear shoes
that's pretty much gone now so so so you
get benefits you get disadvantages but
you can't build walls well of course WTO
is a a legal regime which is intended to
encourage trade while creating a forum
to deal with unfair practices in trade
it's highly imperfect all human
institutions are from the dawn of
civilization every society has sought to
manipulate trade in his favor and of
course for much of what i would call
modern history the tariff or tax on
imports was the mechanism by which that
was accomplished
so called protecting domestic industries
but most economic historians and others
believe that the protectionist response
to the slowdowns of the 1920s and 1930s
contributed to the depression which in
turn contributed to the Second World War
and I I think you have to be very
careful to guard against that now it's a
very different world now there are six
and a half billion people on earth the
population is now expected to grow
although population projections on a
torus ly unreliable because changes can
produce changes in human behavior can
produce shop changes and population
projections but I think the best
estimates now will will peak between
eight billion and nine billion that's an
enormous number of people with a huge
demand for land for water for food for
the education to think that you can deal
with those issues and ninety percent of
that population growth will occur in
poorer areas think you can deal with
that by creating protectionists walls I
think it's a profound error
you